my mom is the net first an incredible
gentle spirit who taught me everything I
know so my mom is my mom is Dorian
eemiller my mom is Marilyn Dressler my
mom is Christian Gilmore pine you know I
feel like there's not too many people
you come across a know we're up there
like every moment you have together is
just like intrinsically beautiful she is
an amazing woman the most stubborn a
strongest woman I've ever met she really
pushed me she really she really
motivated me to do all these things she
helped me she could make everybody her
friend kind of I think that's something
that she gave to me I know a lot of
people like in this world like they hold
grudges she had an incredible ability to
forgive
[Music]
my mother died of pneumonia you ever
seen my father cry for the first time
but other than that I don't really
remember much outside of home videos my
mom got really sick when I was really
young they missed the lump and one of
her breasts and the lump spread to her
second breast hit her lymph node stomach
back and brain and they only gave her
six weeks to live and I was a sophomore
in high school at the time my mom was
diagnosed with a rare form of breast
cancer and in September of 2014 she
passed away I didn't really know how
cancer was gonna work I didn't know how
quickly it would act she passed on me
first we buried her May 3rd my birthday
is May 5th I graduated on Mother's Day
May 9th is one thing to like lose a
parent you know it's also like another
thing that lose the best friend I think
that it's it's not something you ever
really get over know you just learn to
understand what it means I just learned
a lot harder I lived in fear for many
many years of my life she would she was
sick for eight years before she finally
passed away every morning I would go to
school not sure if she'd be there when I
got home she was such a good person that
that would listen and just give eloquent
and intelligent and thoughtful responses
and care and caring responses I used to
have to like do those science fair
projects too everybody has to do with
like the poster board and everything
like that and my mom would like get more
excited about the project than I would
so like I would stay up all night long
putting together what I thought was an
incredible project and I will wake up
and like the poster board would be
completely different it would be like
cut out and like tricked out it'll be
like 3d and all of this stuff it we
would just had this moment where I would
just like look there and she look at me
and I remember coming home with the
first place medal
and I was just like mom we did it and
she was like yeah you did that the day
after she had this brain operation I
wrote this paper and it was garbage and
she took it and she revamped the whole
thing and when I got it I was like I
this is even sound like I wrote this on
anybody can submit this she's like
you'll be fine just to submit it and I
got the paper back the next day and I
got a b-plus and she was so pissed
because she didn't get an A and that's
the type of person she was as I grow
older and realized more how my mom kept
it together for us and how long she
fought to stay alive to be around for
her children that's up to my mama's I
find myself talking to my mom at least
once twice a day certain times I talk
less sometimes we talk more you know
really depends on how bad of a day I'm
having say I to her every day sometimes
out loud sometimes not
I felt like intrinsically like she
became my Argonaut like she gave her
life to be a protector for me
and so I got this tattoo that says Argo
and I got it at all lowercase because
she was an extremely humble person but I
got it in bold because her presence was
felt wherever she went and I got it on
my forearm because I wanted to wear her
bravery on my sleeve mom I just want to
say I love you and thank you for
everything you've been still doing even
though she's not physically here my mom
is still very much a part of me and Who
I am
every day thank you for everything
thank you for your sacrifices and
everything you did for me for Sep from
it I hope we made you proud everything
that we've done is because of you
everything we've wanted to do everything
we've driven for is because of you mom I
love you so much and I miss you every
day and I still think about you every
day even though I only had it for a
limited amount of time I feel so lucky
to have the bond that I did with my
mother we used to have this thing where
like we would never say goodbye so let's
not go back let's just see you later and
[Music]
I'm okay
we're okay I love you
[Music]
you